ian brossât bonjour
frédéric bihet bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin pour revenir sur l'actualité
politique de ces dernières heures et
notamment la question du pouvoir d'achat
je le disais avec s'est invité dans la
campagne avec le candidat communiste
fabien roussel il promet le roux
scellement en opposition aux
ruissellements des manuels macron qu'il
appelait d'ailleurs plutôt premier de
cordée regarder
pour que notre société aille mieux il
faut des gens qui réussissent je ne
crois pas aux ruissellements mais je
crois à la corde et si on commence à
jeter des cailloux sur les premiers de
cordée
c'est toute la corde et qui dégringole
leroux tellement fait augmenter les
salaires et les retraites parce que
quand on augmente les salaires et les
retraites c'est de l'argent qui va aller
directement dans l'économie réelle qui
va aller dans les commerces qui va aller
dans nos pme c'est de rendre du pouvoir
d'achat aux français
vient de brossage je me tourne vers vous
justement pour nous parler de ce trou
scellement comment on fait pour
augmenter les salaires c'est 1500 euros
nets 1 que veut fabien roussel
aujourd'hui qui paye
comment on fait on fait en faisant payer
ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup payé ces
dernières années ont fait payer
l'entreprise et notamment les grosses
entreprises aujourd'hui dans notre pays
il y a beaucoup de richesses qui sont
produits que nous sommes la sixième
puissance économique du monde quand j'en
entends certains j'ai l'impression qu'on
est en pays en voie de développement non
la france est un pays très riche qui a
largement les moyens de le payer les
augmentations de salaires aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans un système absurde où
le gouvernement dit j'augmente les
salaires en augmentant les primes ce qui
fait qu'on a des salariés qui
travaillent à temps plein et qui sont
obligés d'aller mendier des primes à la
casse dont l'augmentation des salaires
ça passe par une vraie augmentation du
smic et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous préconisons une augmentation
du smic à 1500 euros brut ce qui
correspond à 1500 euros net et ça nous
paraît absolument indispensable pour
permettre que notre pays le monde du
travail soit traité un peu plus
dignement pierre ferret billets les
réformes fiscales de 2018 dont la fin de
l'impôt sur la fortune elle devait
justement stimuler l'économie réelle
mais les conclusions d'un rapport de
france stratégie et est bien pu publier
en octobre dernier ne va pas dans ce
sens regarder
l'observation des grandes variables
économiques croissance investissement au
flux de placements financiers des
ménages etc avant et après les réformes
ne suffit pas pour conclure sur les
faits réels de ces réformes sur les
effets de la réforme isf sur le tissu
économique on ne relève pas de
différence de comportement depuis la
réforme de 2018 entre les entreprises
très exposée est peu exposé à liez f
clerc frédéric milhas comme nous
l'expliquait ian brossât la théorie du
ruissellement finalement aujourd'hui ça
marche pas
non ça marche pas il ya une fantastique
de réformer les sf par un impôt sur la
fortune immobilière mais c'est à des
courses 4 milliards de perdu en termes
de revenus pour l'état
pas d'amélioration plus que ça sur
l'économie le revenu disponible brut
selon l'insee a baissé en 2020 pour tous
les français moins de véhicules 4% bon
le pig an là dessus sur pour d'achat des
macros et est mauvais il faut dire les
choses c'est de l'entre-deux alors soit
on fait un choix de supprimer est
réellement guy sf est pas le remplacer
soit on fait comme les communistes le
propose de faire un vrai isf un triplé
j'en sais rien en tout cas c'est ce que
monsieur roussel propose mais soit on
fait un choix effectivement si biais là
dessus et où quelqu'un on a une
politique très claire soi soit on fait
un choix de dire bah y'a pas dit sdf
parce que pour revenir et puis à l'avoir
mis en place or le terme d'image à
l'extérieur c'est pas beau et puis c'est
une politique qui a affiché entier
riches qui il me semble-t-il pas très
intelligente parce qu'on a besoin de
gens qui ont de l'argent parce qu'elle
chante pour le marchand reste en france
et font vivre une économie autour d'eux
donc c'est un choix qui est née entre
eux deux et pour autant c'est là où je
rejoins monsieur roussel quand on
regarde l'évolution du patrimoine des
plus riches il n'a jamais autant évolué
que ce fait mais macron dockers
d'affichage mais la réalité est très
différente
un point de convergence donc on l'a
entendu entre vous deux ian brossât
quand on taxe les plus riches néanmoins
ce qui n'a pas effectivement ce risque
de les voir partir
lorsque emmanuel macron à supprimer
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
c'était avec la promesse que beaucoup de
familles très riches allaient revenir or
ça n'est absolument pas ce qu'on a
constaté la réalité d'ailleurs la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale l'a prouvé
c'est que isf était payé par trois cent
cinquante huit mille personnes qui à
elle seule possède et 1028 milliards
d'euros de patrimoine et ça c'était en
2017 imaginer le patrimoine qu'elles ont
aujourd'hui sachant notamment que le
coût de l'immobilier a largement
augmenté c'est à dire que ces gens se
sont enrichis en dormant en ne faisant
strictement rien ce n'est pas de
l'argent qui circule dans l'économie et
donc je pense que dans notre pays on a
besoin de s'attaquer à cette question
des inégalités et des injustices qui ont
énormément augmenté pendant le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro je pense à
la baisse des apl par exemple qui a
touché de plein fouet des familles
extrêmement modeste remettre de la
justice revenir à la république sociale
c'est ce que nous proposons avec fabien
au sel c'est le programme de fabien
roussel ça nous changera et je pense que
ça fera du bien pas seulement aux plus
modestes mais aussi aux classes moyennes
mais aussi à ceux qui travaillent à nos
retraités qui ont travaillé toute leur
vie et qu'on voit parfois dans les files
de l'aide alimentaire et c'est une honte
dans un pays comme le nôtre et
s'attaquer également fermement à
l'évasion fiscale c'est ce que disait
fabien roussel dimanche hors de son nid
qui regardent et
nous rétablirons lui et on lui trouvera
même
oui
oui on rétablira la justice la justice
fiscale oran dans l'import plus juste
plus progressif plus léché pour les
petits et plus lourd pour les plus gros
avec nous les politiques de vendredi et
les gros zéro
[Musique]
fini les cadeaux on regarde pas
bourgueil et consorts
frédéric bihet fini les cadeaux aux gars
femmes google il faut qu'ils payent
maintenant
oui alors moi j'ai une certaine
affection pour faire bosser parce que je
trouve que enfin le parti communiste
français
redevient communiste c'est très clair
fabien roussel assume alors moi j'aime
bien parce qu'il dit voilà moi je suis
français j'aime la france j'aime
nucléaire parce que derrière nucléaire
c'est des ouvriers c'est des vrais gens
qui gagnent plutôt correctement leur vie
voilà je défends la baisse trop demi
française etc et puis là une politique
de gauche devraient gauche a su mais
voilà les essais faut que les riches ip
etc au moins ça fait plaisir parce qu'on
voit quelqu'un qui est un vrai
communiste menaces à des ententes ne
l'ait pas vu d'ailleurs sans robben
fortement mélenchon qui est un espèce de
eu un truc un peu entre les deux
communistes les gêne pas là j'aime pas
trop la france etc qui jouent sur des
valeurs comme le wookie sme qui sont pas
très très très très bonne pour d'autres
pays je pense quand il a fallu bosser il
a le mérite de la clarté je trouve qu'il
a un certain talent faut le dire c'est
ces voix là c'est un peu la surprise à
gauche bon alors après sur le smic à
1500 euros il ya un constat global que
tout le monde fait ça c'est clair c'est
qu'il ya un point de pouvoir d'achat des
salaires sont trop bas en france mais ce
que dit fabien roussel sur le smic
globalement il faut revoir tous les
salaires jusqu'à peut-être deux fois une
île au smic comme le dit valérie
pécresse il faut une augmentation des
salaires les français ont des fans mois
ou des milieux de moi trop difficile on
le voit sur les carburants à l'espèce de
prime de 100 euros par ménage battront
c'est c'est quasiment l'aumône c'est pas
au niveau des enjeux aujourd'hui donc je
crois que tous les partis politiques ont
fait l'analyse qui a un réel pouvoir
d'achat d'ailleurs c'est l'une des
principales préoccupations pour la
présidentielle et il faut mettre ça sur
la table il faut un grenelle des
salaires
il faut revoir les impros de production
parce que au delà des salaires il faut
libérer l'énergie des entreprises les
impôts de production sont beaucoup trop
en france jusqu'à cinq fois plus qu en
allemagne et on voit le résultat en
allemagne les salaires sont à négocier
que syndical manière tout à fait
consensuelle et intelligente tous les
deux ou trois ans bref y'a tout ça sur
la table c'est pas alors le smic lisf
sont des gros marqueur de bouche et
c'est leur désir on la connaît mais
derrière ça il ya effectivement la
progressivité des impôts il ya des
impôts de société et quelle société on
veut oui est ce que oui est ce qu'on
veut une société industrielle
quand vous revenir industrie française
moi je le souhaite et valérie pécresse
le souhaitent il ya toutes ces questions
sur la table il faut pas se focaliser
sur les marqueurs qui sont assez faciles
à utiliser à revenir mais il ya
différents sujets sur la table il ya la
semaine des 32 heures aussi je vous
propose d'y revenir dans un instant mais
avant ian brossât peut être un mot sur
le le début des propos de pierre
frédéric bihet c'est vrai que fabien
roussel il a fait un meeting remarqué
mais même à droite il est à 3% comme ali
d'algues aujourd'hui il a su renouveler
le pcf finalement là où le ps a échoué
à le sujet à mes yeux ce n'est pas le
renouveler le pcf seul directeur de
campagne de fabien roussel et j'exerce
cette responsabilité avec beaucoup de
bonheur non je pense que l'idée c'est
surtout de donner des solutions d'espoir
un beaucoup de gens qui aujourd'hui n'en
voit pas le sujet il n'est pas interne
au parti communiste le sujet est que
beaucoup de gens qui auparavant voté à
gauche se sont repliés soit vers
l'abstention soit vers le vote d'extrême
droite des gens du monde du travail
pourquoi parce que la gauche a n'a pas
fait son boulot parce que quand françois
hollande était président de la
république il a dit mon ennemi c'est la
finance et après il s'est couché et donc
ce que nous pouvons faire avec fabien
roussel s'est ramenée à gauche beaucoup
de gens qui se sont perdus en chemin
parce que la gauche ne répondait plus du
doubs à leurs aspirations et je pense
que femme et en sel peut faire ça parce
qu'il partage la vie de millions de nos
concitoyens parce qu'il fait partie de
ces élus eux deux villes de moins de
vingt mille habitants
qui qui ont une vie simple et est
content finalement assez peu dans la
crise politique aujourd'hui l'essentiel
des candidats de gauche y vivent en
région parisienne et donc ça nous
changera d'avoir d'avoir quelqu'un comme
fabien roussel et je pense que s'il est
entendu c'est justement parce qu'ils
partagent cette villa et beaucoup de
gens se reconnaissent dans ce qu'il dit
ian brossât vous parliez du travail
justement le débat sur la semaine des 32
heures fabien roussel veut le relancer
le travail et moi pour gagner plus est
ce que c'est pas une fausse promesse est
ce que c'est vraiment à cela que ce
vraiment cela que veulent les
travailleurs aujourd'hui
nous ne disons pas qu'il faut imposer
cette mesure à tout le monde et
l'appliquer de manière autoritaire ce
que nous voyons ça s'est vu récemment
d'ailleurs dans une grosse entreprise de
lyon c'est l'heure c'est que lorsque
pardon des chefs d'entreprise test cette
mesure elle recueille l'assentiment des
salariés dès lors que ça ne passe pas
par une réduction de leur salaire ce qui
est évident mais il constate que ça
engendre une augmentation de la
productivité donc ce que nous souhaitons
effectivement dire dans le dialogue
social par branches c'est d'aller vers
une réduction du temps de travail c'est
effectivement l'objectif que nous fixons
parce qu'on sait que dans un certain
nombre de métiers qui sont des métiers
pénibles la question du temps de travail
se pose elle se pose en compte
concernant la semaine avec cet objectif
deux semaines des 32 heures elle se pose
aussi avec la nécessité pour eux de
pouvoir partir en retraite et nous
sommes effectivement favorables à la
retraite à 60 ans effectivement nous
considérons qu'il vaut mieux travailler
un peu moins mais travailler tous et
travailler dans de bonnes conditions qui
après de rugby est votre réaction sur
cette question le débat sur la semaine
de 32 heures
oui bon valérie pécresse est très clair
là dessus elle est pour la liberté si
une entreprise souhaite revenir aux 39
heures en négociant avec les salariés et
peut le faire les 35 heures les 32
heures c'est déjà arrivé dans certaines
entreprises et ça fonctionne bien en
gros nous qu'on préconise la liberté
choix des négociations entre
l'entreprise des salariés les syndicats
il faut retrouver la voie de la
concertation des entreprises il faut
retrouver cette ambiance de confiance et
d'un projet en commun des entreprises
voilà c'est très clair une petite mesure
qui est passé à la trappe mais qui est
intéressant c'est de réserver 10% du
capital les entreprises en bourse coté
en bourse pour les salariés ça permet de
fixer aussi comment dire les salariés
dans l'entreprise et de fixer les
entreprises en france sur le capital
c'est une mesure qui est passée un peu
la trappe de de valérie pécresse mais je
pense qu'il est tout à fait intéressante
dans les années à venir il nous reste
trois minutes peut-être une réaction
souvient de cette colère des gilets
jaunes sur le pouvoir d'achat il ya une
autre colère qui s'exprime en ce moment
avec le convoi de la liberté
initiée au canada ils s'expriment ils
s'organisent en ce moment en france est
ce que c'est un mouvement qui pourrait
inquiéter la majorité selon vous une
brosse a
en tout cas c'est une c'est une colère
que j'entends effectivement il ya eu la
colère et gilet jaune et on voit bien
comme un certain nombre de mesures dites
écolo finissent par se retourner contre
le monde du travail et moi je ne suis
pas favorable à une écologie qui
consiste en permanence a demandé à ceux
qui ont peu de faire tous les efforts et
on a au contraire besoin de faire une
écologie populaire c'est d'ailleurs un
peu la même problématique qui se pose
chez nous avec l'interdiction des
voitures polluantes d'ici 2025 ce sont
10 millions d'automobilistes 10 millions
d'automobilistes qui vont être privés
d'accès à nos grandes métropoles si on
ne leur permettra si on ne permet pas
pardon d'avoir une voiture moins
polluante et c'est la raison pour
laquelle avec fabien roussel nous
proposons une nouvelle prime à la
conversion pour garantir le droit à la
mobilité de ses 10 millions
d'automobilistes plutôt que les assignés
à résidence
pierre frédéric bihet votre réaction
alors là on avait sur le convoi de la
liberté un convoi qui a été initié au
canada oui alors on s'aperçoit surtout
et on l'a vu avec les gilets jaunes
c'est que maintenant des mouvements
peuvent naître en dehors des
traditionnels syndicales et des
mouvements des corps intermédiaires par
des réseaux sociaux par que les gens se
réunissent ensemble vous menez des
actions des fois très longue les fois
avec force et beaucoup de conviction ça
c'est la première chose et puis la
seconde chose ce que dit monsieur bros
assez importants
auront omis l'écologie assez punitive
avec des gens qui ont des véhicules qui
sont anciens et bien malheureusement
dans
2023/2024 il ya des français qui ne
pourront plus aller à paris emmener
leurs enfants parce que l'on véhicule et
est trop ancien parce qu'ils peuvent 10
en eux ils n'ont plus le droit de rouler
dans la capitale française va prenez
conscience de ce que ça veut dire moi je
suis moi je suis effaré par ce genre de
mesure c'est d'un mépris total pour les
français qui travaillent qui n'ont pas
les moyens de changer de voiture alors
dit monsieur vous n'êtes pas assez bien
vous une voiture n'est pas assez bien
vous pouvez pu venir dans la capitale de
votre pays prenez conscience et 2023
2024 critères à paris c'est une
catastrophe m'a servi à des gens ils
vont une fois par an à paris ils
emmènent leurs enfants devant les gars
lafayette à noël devant le printemps
c'est un moment en famille important est
bas dans un an dans deux ans ces gens là
soit interdit de venir à paris enfin
voila j'ai ainsi décidé c'est une folie
par mois je suis gros ça ira j essaie de
faire du lobbying auprès d'anne hidalgo
dû expliquer ça moi je regrette anne
hidalgo et de vous prendre que bientôt
de campari voyaient leurs effets mais
des meilleurs résultats en tout cas bien
ou c'est en tout cas merci à un dernier
mot à ian brossât quelques secondes oui
juste dire que la métropole c'est la
métropole qui décide des déchets c'est
patrick ollier parle également merci à
tous les deux en tout cas d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin ian
brossât conseiller pcf mairie de paris
et merci à vous prévu pierre frédéric
biais mer les républicains de droite et